- [Voiceover] Hello grammarians,
let's talk about the progressive aspect.
So we talked about the
simple aspect as something
that is just most bare form.
It's what you see here,
I walk, I will walk, I walked.
But aspect allows us
to talk about things that are ongoing.
And that's what we call the progressive
because it's progressing,
it's going, it's happening.
So if we are telling a story
and we are inside that moment,
we can use the progressive aspect.
So I walk becomes, in the present,
I am walking.
So the way the progressive
works is that it takes the form
of to be for whatever the
subject of the sentence is,
in this case I, and it changes
the verb into an ING verb.
That's what it does.
That's what the progressive does.
And its effect is to say
that something is ongoing.
This is also called the continuous aspect,
but I like to call it
the progressive aspect.
Let's try this in all the
different basic conjugations.
So we call this the present progressive.
Let's try the past progressive.
So if it says I walked,
we would just take the verb to be
and then put it in the past.
So this part doesn't change,
the walking doesn't change.
You would say, I was walking.
Likewise, for the future,
so we're not gonna
change the walking part,
we're just gonna put this
am part into the future,
which is like so, I will be walking.
That's the future progressive.
So the way to remember
the progressive aspect
is for me to hideously butcher
the writing of David Mamet
and tell you to always remember your ABCs.
Always
be
conjugating.
And conjugating here is
just a word that means
to put verbs in different
tenses and aspects,
but I really want you to focus on the fact
that we've got this be and this ING.
So just remember be and ING
and that's how you form the progressive.
So no matter whether or not
it's happening in the past,
it's still I was walking.
So the part that changes is
the be, is the verb to be.
I was walking, I am
walking, I will be walking.
The part that doesn't
change is the walking
and that's how you express
that something is ongoing,
that something is continuously happening
in the telling of the story.
Understanding this will
enable you to master time.
You can learn anything.
David out.